This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you've done. need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your
podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins, but the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. And welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big
life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody, welcome back to the show, welcome back to the podcast, new listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode. This week, we're tackling a rather big, scary topic in our 20s, one that I imagine many of us have struggled with at some point in our lives, especially during this decade. we're going to take a dive into the psychology behind loneliness, both the good and the bad, and kind of reach some conclusions, not only about the origins of loneliness during this decade,
what it means for our well-being, how to quote-unquote cure this feeling, but also how to feel comfortable with being alone and embrace loneliness as an important part of our goal. growth. I think we are really kind of sold this contrived narrative that our 20s are this golden decade and we should be surrounded by friends, we should be dating, we should be going out and socializing and have a large social network. It's where we meet our forever friends. And this has been sold to us across multiple platforms from social media to shows like friends and new girl
where there are these really romanticized depictions of really close friendship groups. So when we don't feel that way, when we don't meet that expectation, we can really feel like failures and like something is wrong with us. One thing I want to say before we begin is that contrary to what popular culture has to say about this decade, it is really normal to feel lonely in your 20s. even if you are someone who is surrounded by people, something that I've noticed is that we often don't want to admit when we are feeling this way, not even to those who are closest to us. There is this strange stigma almost around loneliness that prevents us from talking about it and prevents us from normalizing it. You know, this strange sense that if we come out and outright say, I feel lonely. I am lonely, that people will think there is something wrong with us or that we don't have friends or that we are unenjoyable to be around.
And 99% of the time, that is not true. The loneliness is at its core a biological and emotional reaction, more so than an environmental one. It has less to do with the quantity of our friendships or social relationships and more to do with our internal experience. experiences and perception of the world, the quality of our connections and at its core, our relationship with ourselves. Of course, there are many times when we naturally are inclined to feel lonely because of our environment, maybe you've just moved to a new city or you've gone through a breakup. But I think we as a generation do need to become more comfortable with being alone with solitude, with our own emotions, and with sometimes feeling uncomfortable. That may
seem really hard. Loneliness is a really hard feeling, but my goal is to really share how we can embrace it and really treat it as an important enabler for our growth rather than feel threatened. There is a lot to talk on today and I really want to do this topic justice, especially because I know it's probably something on a lot of our minds. There is not a person I know who hasn't at times felt this way, who hasn't at times felt lonely. So we are going to dive into exactly why our 20s can produce such intense feelings of isolation, the neurological and internal basis for these feelings, some of the dangers and downsides. But ultimately, how we can embrace solitude, embrace loneliness and harness its benefits rather than being consumed by the negativity and the fear.
Ultimately, the title of this episode truly does say it all. Loneliness is not our enemy. So let's get right into it and uncover all of the science and psychology that confirms this. Loneliness is incredibly hard. I feel like that is not something that I need to repeat very often throughout. this episode because we all know it. And I do want to start this episode on a personal note. You know, I think I have a very complicated relationship with feeling lonely. Even though I know it's natural, I know it's common, I know all of the reasons why it happens,
but there is just this thing where since I was young, the idea of feeling lonely or not being surrounded by people has been really, really terrifying. I was trying to explain that. this to a friend the other day, but ever since I was a child, I've had this weird experience, you know, these like three month cycles where I will go through periods of feeling super happy, super supported, super content. And then like clockwork, I just get this entirely irrational, sinking feeling that I am lonely. And I cannot shake it. And the interesting thing is that each time this happens, nothing has really changed about my environment. It's, It's entirely mental and it's something that has really been part of my life for a long time.
I feel like I often think of myself as a lonely person even though I'm surrounded by such wonderful people. And I was talking to my therapist about it and this is basically what really inspired me to make this episode because I'm sure that I'm not in this boat on my own. I'm sure it's not just me. And as my 20s have gone by, I found that the feeling has gotten worse. What she explained to me is that this habit of anticipating a future loneliness or feeling an impending sense of loneliness is a fear response very similar to catastrophizing or future prepping, whereby I, and I'm sure many others, try and unconsciously avoid feelings of loneliness by artificially mimicking the feeling to prepare ourselves for when this situation may occur. If this sounds really strange or really complicated, I totally understand. I was kind of confused when she first told me this, but when we dive further into the biology and the evolutionary underpinnings, it makes a lot more sense why sometimes we feel lonely without any apparent cause or shift.
Repeated and consistent human interaction is vital for our mental well-being and our mental health. I think we all know that. We all know that social health is part of the broader holistic health that we bring through our lives. But on a deeper level, we don't like feeling alone or isolated because evolutionarily our survival rested on feeling connected with others. This is an explanation I've given before on the podcast, but I still find it really valuable to share. Our prehistoric ancestors, they relied on the existence of tribal networks and groups to ensure their survival. Membership to a group provided us with security. More access to food.
It provided us with shelter, mating partners and protection. Without it, if we were cast out, if we were socially isolated, if we lost our group, our chances of survival were very slim. And that part of our mind that has adapted to that former reality is still very much alive. According to countless studies, I couldn't even name them all, our minds have essentially evolved to promote our survival through social connection. And feelings of loneliness are a neural mechanism of drawing us back into the protection of a Because whilst loneliness may be painful, it's a much better alternative to being out on our own and therefore being
killed by a hungry beast or dying from exposure, as was likely the case back in the day if we rejected our social group or they rejected us. It is essentially our instinct to seek out social comfort and connection. There is this amazing article that was written by Discover Magazine. a very good subscription if you are thinking of getting into it. And it was written by Dr. Stephanie Cacopo. She's a professor of behavioral neuroscience in the UK and she described it perfectly. Basically, what she concluded is that loneliness is very similar to those kind of biological hunger or thirst cues that we get because it reminds us to reconnect with those around us to to ensure survival the same way that hunger and thirst protect our physical well-being
and tell us to seek out important nutrients and resources for our physical survival. It's all very much tied into our basic instincts and our basic urges. Loneliness gets a bad rap and there used to be an argument in psychology that loneliness was actually an emotional fault or a defect in our DNA. that actually shouldn't exist because it was super negative, it made people feel really bad about themselves, but also there was this argument that other species did not experience loneliness and they were still surviving. So essentially this feeling wasn't entirely necessary. Not only do we now know that that is wrong, many species like elephants and great apes, even big cats,
they experience loneliness as well, but also, So if the outcomes of feeling lonely were entirely negative, according to Darwin's theory of evolution, it would no longer be part of our DNA, because members of our species who did contain this proclivity wouldn't have survived if it was entirely harmful. That's kind of a wrap-around, roundabout logic to explain evolution, right? You know, if something is not important for our survival, it does not survive in our DNA due to breeding and the survival of offspring that have that quality. But we know that loneliness is still very much part of the human instinct and the human experience because it does have a value. It is important.
It serves as a self-protection and preservation mechanism. It basically acts as this little feeling in our brain telling us. us to reach out, telling us to reconnect. Okay, we spent a lot of time in the science. I'm realizing that now, and that was not my intention, but I really want to dive into some of the more environmental and situational variables that can be a catalyst for loneliness, especially in this decade. Regardless of why we experience loneliness, whether it's biological, whether it's social,
it still feels really terrible. And our 20s are actually one of the times where we can feel at our lowest when it comes to this feeling. A study done by the Office for National Statistics out in the UK and actually found that young adults between the ages of 18 and 29 were actually three times more likely
to feel lonely compared to older age groups. This is really interesting to me because I think our typical picture of loneliness is very much, you know, an elderly person, locked in their home, you know, who has lost all of their family members and friends, but that's not the case. It's actually this generation, this age group, my age group, your age group, that is suffering the most. Some reasons why I think it is more common in our 20s comes down to the number of significant levels. life transitions and changes that we are all going to experience in this decade. We graduate high school, we leave the security of a convenient inbuilt community that is our schooling system, and we go out into the world on our own. And for most of us, that also involves saying goodbye to friendships and connections and mentors that you naturally outgrow. For most of us, our 20s are also a time when we
move out of the family home and we leave the orbit of our close family, specifically our parents. At first, this might feel incredibly liberating to be free of parental supervision and have our independence, but it's also very comforting to have that stable family unit. When we fly the nest, we can often find ourselves a little bit nostalgic once the excitement has worn off and a little bit lonely because we no longer have that stable structure that we can go back to every night and be comforted by. Whilst loneliness is in part evolutionary and biological, it's also in part of reaction to community. When we feel without community or a strong present support network, that's often when that dark feeling can come on strongest.
and family really does play a crucial role in that. As someone who is also moving into the mid-stage of my 20s, I would say there's another thing that I've noticed, particularly in the last year, which I don't think I've really seen many people talk about this. It's rarely spoken about in relation to our 20s. And that is how many of our friends begin to enter new chapters or have different timelines than our own.
often leading to what I would call disconnection and growing apart from the people that we used to feel closest with. Let me explain that a little bit more. It's not even fully formed in my brain, but I do just think it's worth sharing. I think the first 18 years of our lives are very much cut and paste for most of us. You know, we go to school, we go to high school, we do sports, we do music, we do all of the things. And then, suddenly, you're 23, one of your friends is about to get married, some of your friends are still at uni, half of you are working full time, another one is off in Peru exploring the world, you're all scattered across the country, and friendship is no longer convenient. It's something
I have personally experienced recently. I moved to Sydney last year, and most of my close girlfriends remained in Canberra, which is where I went to university. And I was catching up with one of them recently. And in the past year, even in the past month, one of them has decided to move to this tiny island off of Australia. One of them is moving to London. And the other is in the midst of doing her honours. And I just realized that everything was changing. And we only had a few more opportunities to really truly be together as a group. And for some reason, I just felt so lonely. Not because these people were no longer in my life, not because we had had a falling out. One of them was literally sitting across from me, but because everything was changing and everything was new
and I didn't really know where I was going to land. And I was kind of comforted by knowing that my reaction was not only normal but really supported by theory. Psychologists have this idea that there are three major conditions for making and keeping good friends. These are proximity, repeated interactions and settings that encourage authenticity. Those three conditions for healthy long-term friendships become a lot harder as things in our life change. The older we get, people move away. You no longer have repeated interactions that were often brought on by the closeness of university or school or college.
You don't live in the same place anymore. And it's not to say that you can't successfully maintain long-distance friendships. It's just that the dynamic and the nature of the relationship changes. and with that there's an adjustment period that loneliness tends to crop up in. These simultaneous transitions, I would say contribute to a sense of isolation and in part confusion about what happens next, which is a massive trigger for loneliness. There are some other typical events and experience that I think contribute to social isolation the further we get into our 20s as we enter the workforce.
in particular, the amount of time that we have to build and maintain healthy connections is minimised by paid obligations. It's minimised by work. Socialising is now reserved for the hours before 9am and after 5pm, and that is a small window compared to what we're used to. We just simply have less time. That's the truth about getting older and having responsibilities. Our priorities change, not just with work and our careers, but also with the entry of long-term romantic partners. I'm sure we've all had an experience whereby a friend gets into a relationship and suddenly is very inaccessible. Maybe you have been that person yourself. I could keep listing reasons here. You know, we could talk about breakups, we could talk about simply outgrowing people, we could talk about kids even. There are so many
reasons. I think it's all just a really confusing time whereby the moment we begin to feel steady and feel secure, things suddenly change. And the easier kind of social interactions that we often relied on for stimulation and for fulfillment and that we often took for granted become a lot harder, as does a sense of community, which I think is a really vital protective mechanism against loneliness. There's also more personal factors. I think I've talked a lot about situational and environmental variables, but we also change as people. This period in our life is so formative. The person I was at 21, let alone 18, is so, so different to the version of me now. And so my ability to connect and feel seen also changes, especially as we step into a new identity, everything is so
confusing. And if we don't really know ourselves quite yet, if we're still in that growth phase, it's really hard to feel that others know us deeply and therefore we don't feel connected. I think that's also really common amongst this decade. It's not so much that there aren't people around us. That's a big thing. It's not so much that you don't have friends. It's that those friendships become harder. There are other factors that begin to play a role, different priorities. And at the same time, something we forget is that we're still trying to figure out exactly who we are and how we can best connect with other people. All of that is just to say loneliness is a quintessential experience of our 20s. And although it is unpleasant, I think that we can actually change our relationship to this
feeling to be one that is productive rather than fearful. Loneliness has a lot of beneficial functions, which we're going to talk about in just a second. I think most crucial, though, is that if we don't learn how to be alone, if we are so fearful of this experience that we rush into any new relationship or friendship that walks through the door, we can actually do a lot more harm than good. Sometimes it is good to embrace solitude to get a better understanding of who you are and what you want and what you deserve in relationships. So I kind of want to move past some of that dwelling we've done on the downsides and the origins and focus more on how we can embrace this feeling,
all of that in more in just a second. If you are feeling lonely right now, and that's why you're listening today, I want to firstly, before we get into the rest of the episode, give you three bits of truth, or I guess, many affirmations that have always comforted me. The first one, which I honestly stand by, is that you have not yet met all the people who will love you in this life.
It's very easy in our 20s to see things without a great deal of perspective because this is all that we've experienced, right? Like we're baby adults. This is like the first time that we're experiencing a lot of this stuff, the first time we're experiencing, you know, moving to a new place and losing friends and adjustments. So it's important to sometimes. have the hindsight that people give us from older generations or older, wiser people,
that there is so much yet to come that is even better than what has already transpired. The second one is that we are never truly alone. I think our brain convinces ourselves that we are, especially with what we were talking about before, about anticipatory anxiety and catastrophizing to kind of protect us and ensure our survival and finally, nothing stays the same for long. This feeling will pass as all good and bad things in life do. We've acknowledged that loneliness can be unpleasant.
We all know that I think on a personal and anecdotal level, but I do also think there is something really sacred in solitude and sometimes that can produce loneliness as a side effect and that's something that we just have to come to terms with as part of the terrain. Here's the truth. At some point, you are going to feel lonely regardless of all of your efforts, and maybe that is you right now. Obviously, we can understand that loneliness is painful, but there is this idea that when we fear something, we let it control us. And if we fear being alone, we allow it to control our enjoyment of life and the
decisions we make regarding the quality of our relationships and who we choose to spend our time with. If we are lonely and if we are scared of being lonely, often, like I said, we just jump at the first thing that walks through the door without properly thinking about where that relationship or that friendship is going to sit in our life. I really want to change the narrative around loneliness for those reasons, because I think it's beneficial to sometimes feel alone. And I do want to think of it as an attitude of gratitude and stoicism rather than one of fear and anticipation. I think we need to have a greater appreciation for what solitude can bring us so that we can all, you know, perhaps feel a little bit better and comforted in some of the benefits of this
emotion. Spending time alone is actually incredibly beneficial, especially in our 20s, because it allows us to develop a better understanding of ourselves. It allows us to do the things that we want to do and become more independent. It can sometimes be a blessing. Rather than a curse, studies have shown that the more you know and understand yourself through concentrated efforts to spend time alone, the stronger your value set is and the more likely you are to do things that you love with people that you love, to learn things that interest you, and spend time with people that make
you feel good rather than people that drain your energy. There's also some other surprising benefits that I think we could all probably speak to just on an anecdotal and personal experience, but solitude really does increase productivity. It's just the fact that you don't have the destruction. So there's one upside. It also sparks creativity. creativity because we have more time with our thoughts and we can let them wander and explore new corridors of our brain and it can build mental strength because we have to learn how to rely on ourselves and trust our own ability to manage daily stress and adversity. I will say that this is not always optimal. You know, we do overcome things easier and sooner with the help of a support network
but I really want to demonstrate that it's not all doom and gloom and that if you are going through a period of loneliness it's not all bad right like there are some upsides I know it sounds really like tokenistic to say that but I think with everything when you have a better mindset you get through something quicker and all of these kind of benefits really do help develop that positive attitude towards your experiences I think loneliness is also sometimes really valuable because it allows us to reassess the value of our close relationships.
Often, loneliness is situational, but sometimes it can be caused by just feeling like you don't belong. Relationships are meant to cultivate the best feelings about yourself. They are meant to make you feel happy and fulfilled. So if you feel lonely amongst certain people, even when they're around you, it really is an indicator, a mental indicator that we need to take a closer look at whether these relationships are really what we want in our lives. I think sometimes loneliness indicates to us that we want to be close with people, we want to stay in touch, but we also want to prioritize quality time. You know, it's something that we haven't really talked on yet, but I do honestly believe it's better to feel lonely with yourself than alone with others. It's just something that I think of sometimes when I'm going through periods like this. And like I said, this doesn't have to be
your enemy when we, A, recognize that it's normal and that it will pass. I promise it will pass. And B, we embrace some of the opportunities. It provides rather than distracting ourselves. There are a few ways that we can really live this philosophy, and I know it's hard. I don't want to discredit that, but if you want to embrace solitude, you have to start before you begin to feel lonely. I have been frequently doing this since I was like maybe 19, where I go away for either one or two days at a time just by myself. I go camping or hiking, and it allows me to escape my reality because I want to show myself that I can do things alone and activate some of those benefits to feel creative, to feel independent, to feel productive. To be honest, I began this
habit or these little activities or trips when I was going through a really rough time at university. I was really depressed. I was really distanced from people. My grades weren't great. And it was almost this self-inflicted challenge to see if I could do it. I'd become really codependent on someone I was dating, but also really anxious about my friendships. And it was like the first time that I really had a big group of friends. And it was really scary to me that these people could leave or go away. And I wanted to force myself to confront that fear of being alone just for a few days.
to prove myself that everything could fall apart, I could be entirely by myself, and I would still be okay. If that sounds confusing, let me explain it a little bit more. I think being able to tolerate loneliness and adapt to it is a skill, and you don't really want to be using any skill for the first time when things are really dire. So by doing these solitary trips or even activities, it could be as simple as going for a day trip by yourself or to the movies, we slowly adjust our minds to accept loneliness and acknowledge that being alone will sometimes be our reality, but we will get through it. So when we do feel this way, we see fewer of the negative emotional effects, really, and we know how to handle it. We're able to activate the benefits. These solitude trips have taught me so much about myself. It's
ridiculous. It has made me enjoy my own company so much more. It has made me show myself more self-love. It has made me think deeper about my feelings and what I want. And it's just made me realize that our lives are so busy. And especially if you're a people-pleaser, we give up so much of our time to pleasing others and also because we don't want to feel lonely, right? We just out days of always so full with interactions and obligations and when you force yourself to take a step back and embrace solitude, it is such a sacred and beautiful time and I highly recommend it to anyone who either has a complicated relationship with feeling lonely or just wants to grow a little bit further in themselves and their own soul. I think another way to embrace loneliness is to
acknowledge that it is a natural response to something that you need and that your needs are not being met. It's not something that's wrong with you and it doesn't always have to be a need that has a social origin. Sometimes loneliness emerges from not feeling connected with ourselves. Really sit and think about that for a second. Is it because you are genuinely alone that you feel this way? or because deep down you don't really feel like you know yourself well enough to ask for what you need or to ever feel satisfied in any relationship. The natural instinct is to minimize this feeling by filling up our days and socialising. But at the end of the night or at the end of the week, we will find ourselves back in the same position of not knowing.
承认这是对你所需事物的一种自然反应，说明你的需求没有得到满足。这并不是你自身出了什么问题，而且这种需求也不一定非得具有社会根源。有时孤独感源于我们感觉与自己缺乏真正的联系。请静下心来仔细想想这句话。你感到这种情绪是因为你真的孤身一人，还是因为在内心深处，你觉得自己根本不够了解自己，无法表达出自己真正需要什么，也无法在任何亲密关系中感到真正的满足？人的本能是通过把日程排满和进行社交来尽量缩小这种感受。但到了深夜或周末结束时，我们会发现自己又回到了那种一无所知的原点。
and not knowing ourselves well enough, and the toxic cycle kind of continues. Like I said, spend a day each week, if you can, filling up your own cup so that you can firstly feel connected with yourself, and secondly, you can show up better in your interactions to make them more meaningful. It kind of heals two parts of you at once. It heals the connection and the relationship you have with yourself, and it makes your friends. friendships and your relationships of a much higher quality. I think it's also important to practice forms of self-care that are dependent on you rather than stimulation from others. That really helps us grow our independence and feel less fearful of being alone and schedule activities with
并且因为不够了解自己，这种有毒的循环便会继续下去。就像我所说的，如果可以的话，每周花一天时间来丰盈自己的内心，这样一来，首先你能感受到自己与内在的联系，其次你能在人际交往中表现得更好，让交往变得更有意义。这相当于同时疗愈了你的两部分。它疗愈了你与自己的连接和关系，也让你的友谊和人际关系质量大大提升。我认为同样重要的是，去实践那些依赖于你自身、而不是靠外界刺激来维持的自我关怀方式。这确实能帮助我们培养独立性，减少对孤独的恐惧，并为你真正享受的活动安排时间。
friends that you actually enjoy. It's important to remember that different people are going to need differing levels of social interaction and connection. I'm speaking about extroverts, versus introverts, you don't need to go the entirely different way and completely cut yourself off from everyone to embrace feeling lonely. That's not what I'm suggesting. Hopefully no one thought that, but that's going to do a lot more harm than good. It's about finding balance between being able to spend time alone, feeling okay with feeling lonely every now and again because it's natural and it's normal, but then also knowing that the support of others having a great support network is really vital for our well-being and it will come if you don't have it now. There have been times
与你真正喜欢的朋友一起。必须记住的是，不同的人需要不同程度的社交互动和连接。我指的是外向者与内向者的区别，你不需要走向完全极端的另一面，为了拥抱孤独感而彻底切断与所有人的联系。那不是我的建议。希望没有人会那样想，因为那样做只会弊大于利。关键在于找到平衡：既能够享受独处时光，又能对偶尔感到的孤独泰然处之，因为这是自然且正常的；同时也要明白，他人的支持以及拥有一个出色的支持网络对于我们的幸福至关重要，如果你现在还没有，它终究会到来。曾经也有过这样的时刻
when I didn't have it. Life surprises you and it gives you what you need and sometimes just the most remarkable people show up when you least expect them and you really do feel seen and you feel heard and connected. I hope what you've taken away from all of this is that loneliness is not only normal, it's also nothing to flee from. It is intuition and it is natural and we don't need to feel panicked or feel the need to grasp onto social connections that really aren't fulfilling us just to avoid feeling lonely. Being lonely is not always a curse, you know, as much as society and television and people try and make us feel like we need to have this massive group of friends or always be fulfilled by the people we're around. That's not the case. It's not a curse. It's not that there's something
当我身边没有这种支持时。生活总是会给你惊喜，它会给予你所需的一切，有时最了不起的人恰恰会在你最意想不到的时候出现，让你真正觉得被看见、被倾听、被理解。我希望你能从中领悟到，孤独不仅是正常的，而且也没什么好逃避的。它是直觉，是自然而然的事情，我们不需要感到恐慌，也不需要为了摆脱孤独而去抓住那些根本无法满足我们的社交关系不放。孤独并不总是一个诅咒，你知道的，尽管社会、电视和周围的人总是试图让我们觉得自己必须拥有一大群朋友，或者总是需要从身边的所有人那里获得精神满足。事实并非如此。这并不是诅咒。并不是说你身上有什么
wrong with you. I think we just need to reframe our relationship with solitude and being alone and recognize that sometimes it's necessary to go through these periods in order to grow and in order to reprioritize our relationships and our knowledge of ourselves, there's also a lot of psychological benefits. Like I said, everything in a healthy dose, but if you are going through this now, I am sending you so much strength, but also a lot of credit.
不对劲的地方。我想我们只需要重新定义我们与独处的关系，认识到为了成长、为了重新厘清我们的关系以及对自我的认知，经历这些时期有时是必要的，这也有很多心理上的好处。就像我说的，任何事情都要适度，但如果你现在正经历这段时期，我向你送去满满的力量，同时也对你表示由衷的赞赏。
It's really hard. It's really hard to feel that way. And I promise that this won't last forever. you are a wonderful person who people love and if you feel disconnected right now I promise it gets better like I said you haven't yet met all the people who are going to love you in this life friends partners family members there are so many people out there who really do care so embrace this time for what it's teaching you and above all else I think show yourself some great and take care of yourself. Thank you so much for listening to today's episode. It did feel like
这真的很不容易。有这种感受真的很艰难。我向你保证，这一切不会永远持续下去。你是一个大家都深爱着的优秀之人，如果你现在感到与外界失联，我向你保证情况会好转的。正如我所说，在这段人生中，那些将要爱你的人——朋友、伴侣、家人——你还没有全部遇到。外面有那么多真正关心你的人，所以请张开双臂去拥抱这段时间，去体会它教给你的道理，最重要的是，我认为请好好善待自己，照顾好自己。非常感谢大家收听今天的节目。
a bit of a rant at times. It's just something I've been mulling over and talking about so much recently. Loneliness is so stigmatized. It is not talked about enough. So I just wanted to share a bit of my own experience and I'm going to come out and say, I've been feeling lonely. It's not because I don't have great friends or a beautiful family. I know it's because that, I've just been feeling really disconnected from myself. I haven't been prioritizing friendships that are worthwhile and interactions that are worthwhile. And I know sometimes it's just biology. It's just my brain trying to warn me or do something funny to ensure my survival in a world that no longer exists.
有时感觉这期节目有点像是在发牢骚。这只是我最近一直在琢磨、一直在谈论的话题。孤独感带有太多的污名化色彩。关于它的讨论还远远不够。所以我只是想分享一点我自己的经历，我要坦白地说，我最近也一直在感到孤独。这并不是因为我没有好朋友或是温馨的家庭。我知道这是因为，我最近感觉自己和内心的连接断开了。我没有把精力放在那些真正有价值的友谊和有意义的互动上。我知道有时这只是生物学的本能。这只是我的大脑在试图警告我，或者在为了确保我在一个早已不复存在的残酷世界中生存下来而搞一些恶作剧。
So it's all very interesting and very nuanced. But at the end of the day, I'm going to say it again, loneliness is not your enemy. it gets such a bad rap but it is an important feeling it's just part of feeling human so i really hope you learned something i hope you enjoyed if there is a friend of yours who needs to hear this episode please send them a link share the love pass it forward and if you do feel called to do so please feel free to leave a five-star review on apple podcasts spotify whatever you're listening right now It really does help the show to grow, reach new people who you think may like it. And it just really makes my day.
所以这一切都非常有趣且微妙。但归根结底，我要再说一遍：孤独并不是你的敌人。它虽然饱受诟病，但却是一种重要的感受，它只是体验人性的一部分。所以我真的希望大家有所收获，希望你们喜欢这期节目。如果你身边的某个朋友需要听听这集节目，请把链接发给他，传递爱心，分享出去。如果你愿意的话，也请随时在苹果播客、Spotify或你目前正在收听的任何平台上留下五星好评。这确实对节目的发展大有帮助，能让更多你觉得可能会喜欢它的人听到。这也确实能让我一整天都心情大好。
So I want to thank you all for all the support recently. It's been amazing how much you have been loving the recent episodes. I love the recent episodes. So maybe that's it. I'm just like, I'm really in it at the moment. There's so much I want to talk about with you. So thank you for following along. And if you have an episode suggestion, I love when people send me ideas.
所以我想感谢大家最近所有的支持。大家对最近几期节目的喜爱程度真的让我惊叹。我也很喜欢最近的节目。所以也许就是这样。我感觉自己最近完全沉浸其中了。有太多话想和你们聊聊。所以谢谢你们一路相随。如果你有想听的节目主题，我很喜欢大家给我提建议。
So please feel free to follow me at That Psychology podcast on Instagram and shoot me a DM if there's something you think that I should cover in our 20s around psychology or just anything really. And have a lovely day. We will be back later this week for another episode. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter.
所以请随时在Instagram上关注我@That Psychology podcast，如果你觉得有什么关于20岁左右的心理学相关话题或者任何事情我应该探讨的，请随时给我发私信。祝大家拥有美好的一天。我们本周晚些时候会推出另一期节目。百分之二。这就是当旁边有自动扶梯可用时，依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。
I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of nests. mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T.W.O.% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast.
欢迎收听我的播客《2%》。我将在节目中剖析习惯、心理韧性、健身背后的科学，以及在我们这个奇特现代世界中培养韧性的方法。经历一些艰难险阻，你就会浴火重生，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己。请在iHeartRadio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《2%》。这就是T-W-O-%。在《回顾过去》播客中。
From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it, with our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. It was a wild year.
从1979年开始，对我来说那是意义重大的一时刻。84年对我来说也很重要。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。在每期节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试着通过我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的嘉宾以及最喜欢的作家，来理解我们是如何度过那段时期的。就像马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊80年代那样。那是一个疯狂的年份。
It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor.
那是一个疯狂的年份。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。请在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《回顾过去》。嘿，大家好，你们正在收听的是由你们最喜爱的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖姆斯主持的《艰难的学习》。这个空间聚焦黑人男性的经历，进行那些在其他任何地方都绝对不安全、无法坦诚进行的对话，但在这里，你是在和一个深谙此道的持证专业人士进行交流。有多少男人身披一副铠甲。
It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern.
它向世界释放出一个信号：你不是好惹的。但这并不意味着仅仅因为你具备这种能力，你就必须去使用它。请在AHA Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《艰难的学习》。在2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的父亲。但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。欧文斯女士，这份特定的测试是你伪造了两次，对吧？我伪造了一次测试。互联网侦探们出动了一大群人，才揭露出一个令人不安的模式。
Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian. Michael Marangini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences.
还有另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格，一名同性恋者。迈克尔·马朗吉尼。我的脑洞大开。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《受困的爱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。
Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
请在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《受困的爱》播客。这是一个iHeart播客。真人保证。本期节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可留下评论。